foreign
[Music]
the new movie 65 was not a bad movie at
all it was actually good and quite above
decent for a mid budget film I don't
know where the bad reviews come from
they might have not even seen the movie
it was an on-point survival sci-fi movie
with quite a few scary dinosaurs and
other Cretaceous reptiles that might
have raised a few eyebrows for their
design but let's not forget that we
don't really know about all the species
diversity during that time on the planet
and there might as well be such
creatures running about the Cretaceous
Earth that we haven't discovered yet in
fossils or they might have never been
fossilized in the first place the movie
was tightly fit for a limited storyline
it had some tragic elements as well as
bringing back the scary in dinosaurs and
also a lot of action but here in this
video we will discuss the creatures that
was seen in It spoilers alert so let's
get into it
well we won't really tell the gist of
the story or anything that might spoil
the storyline just the creatures that
were seen in the movie and let's start
with the E like according animal this
one was seen in the trailer as well and
it seems to be a carnivore or at least a
scavenger the lurks and the murky lakes
and swarms of Earth 65 million years in
the past it could be a small Mosasaur
species maybe a pannoniosaurus judging
by the length which would be around 15
to 20 feet long or five to six meters
then there is also a small Raptor that
emerged and attacked captain Mills oops
spoiler in one of the scenes and KOA in
another this one seems to be a raptor
species judging by its size and the
extra large claw that all the
dromeosauruses all have the exact
species is unknown but it could very
well be a pyro Raptor or an atross
Raptor and it did not have feathers
as we have discussed in the earlier
video about the the dinosaurs that would
be seen in this movie there were a group
of flying pterosaurs that were now seen
more in detail these had enlarged crests
on their heads with long beaks and a
size that was similar to that of a grown
man but with 15 feet or almost 5 meter
wingspans these off the top of my head
their appearance would resemble the tip
of zwara a species of pterodactyls
and yes there was the Unseen killer
pterosaur which by the looks of it would
have been either a large Pteranodon
preying on the smaller Tupac zoiras are
a member of the azakide group of
pterosaurs that dominated Skies of the
lake Cretaceous species of the asdaqide
would include the quetzalcoatlas which
is one of the largest flying creatures
ever known
there is one scene that showcased a
dinosaur that at first looked like a
cute baby T-Rex stuck in a tar pit but
on closer inspection it was quadrupedal
and aside from its extra large head this
novel dinosaur design also had plates
and spikes on its spinal column as well
as a flat but Bob tail the species is as
said novel and non-existent in the
fossil records
immediately after that the next species
of dinosaurs were again a pack of
raptors on the hunt and it was their
prey and these are the fame
velociraptors not Amplified in size like
the ones in the Jurassic movies but more
realistic the size of large turkeys the
movie makers did not design them as
feathered animals but they only had
small quills the Raptor designs were
more in line with those of the early
2000s
so in the TV spots and the trailers we
get to see carnivorous reptiles that
resemble the no thesaurus these
quadrupedal pack Hunters were not a
species of mosasaurus at all neither
were they dinosaurs at all since they're
squatting legs place them in another
reptile group called squamata which
includes lizards and crocodile forms
these deadly creatures around three to
four meters or 10 to 13 feet long would
have been an Undiscovered species
related to the capro circus which was
slim long-legged cousins of Crocs
anyway next dinosaur just as in the
prologue of the Jurassic world Dominion
movie where we get to see the oviraptor
inside a cave here in this movie we will
also get the same thing anoviraptor in a
cave but it won't be the cute act Thief
that you might presume this creature
like the other animals in the kill or be
killed Cretaceous world is also a deadly
predator the egg Thief here is portrayed
as a hunter in the dark and it
challenges the theories of many
paleontologists as should be the case in
science
so anyway I've seen a review that stated
that there were three Tyrannosaurs in
one of the final Acts or scenes of the
movie I guess they don't know what
dinosaurs are LOL la Mao there were
indeed a gigantic pair of Tyrannosaur
species either one of the three
subspecies the Rex imperto or Regina
they were designed to look badass right
from the start like the v-rexes with
those tiny arms and massive jaws with
protruding teeth and a skin texture
similar to the armored v-rexes of King
Kong 2005 over 12 meters or 40 feet long
and 4 meters or 13 feet tall and yes
they hunted in pairs as a Duo of
unchallengeable killers
and lastly as we were about to come to a
close the creature that we discussed in
our earlier video the quadrupedal Apex
Carnival finally made an appearance it
was the same one seen outside the cave
in the rain this wasn't I repeat this
creature wasn't a T-Rex it was
quadrupedal in posture with long for
Limbs and had an armored scaly skin and
a deadly skull with a terrifying jaw
full of conical teeth my best bet would
put this animal in the pseudoseukin
group of reptiles cousin of crocodiles
but had longer legs and I would say it
resembles a razzanandron gobe by the
time went its way off the resonant Grand
gobe was in the Jurassic all the early
Cretaceous and this was 65 million years
ago so it might have been an
Undiscovered species of a pseudosuchin
related to the resident Rod Gobi
probably an evolved descendant of the
deadly animal
as I said earlier the full biodiversity
of animals present 65 million years ago
is still a big mystery remember just a
fraction of a percentage would have been
fossilized and many species would never
have been fossilized in the first place
so we would never know that they existed
at all so the movie took a jump into the
unknown creating their own deadly
reptiles that might have a probability
of existing since there were creatures
like them although not exactly in
Timeline morphology or size anyway I
hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam